of many millions of astronomical bodies
the solar system is comprised of
only a few thousand have been pinpointed
so far
with the inner part of the system
investigated sufficiently well by now
its vast expanses beyond neptune's orbit
still remain to be explored there is a
great number of objects out there
but mankind is aware only of the largest
ones
today i'm going to tell you about one of
them
makimaki which is one of the biggest
objects in the kuiper belt
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
it was pluto that was the first
astronomical body
discovered beyond neptune's orbit it
happened over 90 years ago
back in 1930. unfortunately the
technologies of the day were not
advanced enough to be able to detect dim
objects at large distances that is why
it took another 47 years
before another discovery of a celestial
object in that area of space had been
made
in 1978 sharon was discovered
and the first asteroid beyond pluto's
orbit albion
was detected in 1992 the 1990s
proved to be fruitful in terms of
discovering a string of trans-neptunian
celestial bodies
but at the beginning of the 21st century
there was a positive boom in exploring
remote parts of the solar system
that is when the prominent team of
researchers michael brown
david rabinowitz and chadwick trujillo
pinpointed the most well-known space
objects beyond neptune's orbit among
these
one designated 2005 fy9
can be singled out later on it was to be
renamed into makimaki
this exoplanet was first seen in images
taken on the 31st of march 2005
and four months later on the 29th of
july
information about the newly discovered
celestial object was made available to
the general public
after the official statement from the
research group
when discovered the planetoid was just
slightly dimmer than pluto
as for its location at the time it was
much higher than the ecliptic plane
in the region of the constellation
comaberanises
thanks to archive images makimaki has
been thoroughly studied by now
the planetoid's eccentricity isn't big
at just
0.162 the angle between the planetoids
orbit
and the ecliptic plane is 29 degrees
which is why this object bright and
large as it is
hadn't been noticed before when
exploring those parts of our system
the first researchers had focused on the
ecliptic plane
as they assumed that the chances of
discovering new celestial bodies there
were higher at the time however the
planetoid was located in the upper part
of its orbit
which is why the researchers couldn't
see it makimaki completes a full orbit
around the system's center
every 306 years
it is currently 52.5 astronomical units
away from the sun
the planetoid is going to reach its
ophelia in the year 2033
with a distance to the sun 52.82
astronomical units having receded from
the parent star
and reached its furthest point from it
makimaki will start approaching it
the planetoid is estimated to reach its
perihelion in the year
2187 with the distance separating it
from the sun being 38 astronomical units
at that point on the planetoid's closest
approach to the system's center
its luminosity will be almost the same
as that of pluto
which will enable scientists to collect
more accurate data about it
in terms of its orbit's parameters the
dwarf planet falls into the category of
the so-called
classical objects of the kuiper belt or
qbino
unlike plutinos which are in orbital
resonance with neptune
qb10s lie quite far from this icy giant
that is why the gravitational influence
exerted by neptune over them
is quite negligible on the 23rd of april
2011
makimaki's disc was passing in front of
a dim star in the constellation coma
berenices
thanks to this eclipse it was possible
to estimate the planetoid size
rather accurately its equatorial
diameter
measures one and a half thousand
kilometers
its polar diameter on the other hand
turned out to be 1430 kilometers
which is around 62 percent that of pluto
this earns makimaki the status of the
fourth largest transneptunian object
coming after pluto aerys and haumea
however it may still be beaten by
gongong
whose parameters still haven't been
estimated with a satisfying degree of
accuracy
makimaki's exact mass still remains to
be found
out the planetoid's average density is
estimated at approximately 1.7 grams per
cubic centimeter
which is slightly lower than that of
pluto
this information allows us to gauge the
dwarf planet's mass
at roughly 3 times 10 to the power of 21
kilograms
incidentally it is 4 percent that of the
moon
makimaki's rotation period is around 22
and a half
hours which is quite a lot for a dwarf
planet
it is known that the planetoid faces the
earth with its equator
although the tilt of its axis with
respect to the orbital plane
hasn't been estimated yet
makimaki is admittedly a rather bright
object
the average ratio of its actual
brightness equals around
0.8 first spectral analysis revealed
that the planetoid surface is not
homogeneous
most of it shows a high brightness ratio
reaching 90 percent
still up to 7 percent of the dwarf
planet's surface is dotted with dark
spots
absorbing up to 98 percent of the light
shed on it
these patches are thought to be areas of
surface made up of rocks that are
peculiar to the planetoid
strangely enough later observations
carried out using the galileo national
telescope
showed makimaki's surface as rather
homogeneous
the dark spots reportedly seen on it may
have been
areas of observation or reflections of
an unknown satellite
that happened to be passing over the
dwarf planet's surface
that is why further observations are
needed to settle the question
observations and spectral analysis
revealed that makimaki's surface
is almost as bright as that of pluto it
consists for the most part of methane
ethane and a very small amount of
nitrogen
continuous exposure to powerful
ultraviolet rays
is thought to have produced thorolins
complex hydrocarbon polymers containing
nitrogen
it is thorolens that give methane snow
on the surfaces of trans-neptunian
objects a typical reddish hue
makimaki's surface temperature is
currently estimated at around 29 kelvin
or 244 degrees celsius below
zero when makimaki is in its perihelion
the temperature slightly rises to around
34 kelvin
or 239 degrees celsius below zero
as the melting point of nitrogen and
methane is much higher
it is logical to assume that the
planetoid must be covered with reddish
snow
made up of methane mixed with ethane
nitrogen and
thorolins interestingly observations and
estimates show that methane on
makimaki's surface is crystallized
and appears as rather large grains
around one centimeter in size
as for ethane it looks like grains
measuring around one millimeter in
diameter
and filling smaller crevices and holes
on the planetoid
it goes without saying that in such low
temperatures machiumaki's atmosphere
is bound to be extremely rarified the
density of gases just above the
planetoid
surface is approximately one billion
times as low as that on our earth
the eternal ice the surface is encased
in cannot melt
even on the planetoid's closest approach
to the sun
[Music]
besides most of the solar energy
reaching the dwarf planet
rebounds back into space on account of
the object's high albedo
for a long time it was thought that
makimaki didn't have any satellites
however in 2015 a group of american
researchers did detect a celestial body
orbiting the planetoid
that's when its main parameters were
gauged the object hasn't been given a
name yet
and for now is officially catalogued as
s-2015
still the satellite was informally
nicknamed mk2
as usual a quick overview of the basic
parameters
to begin with mk2 is a small and
dark celestial body that reflects around
seven percent of all light shed on it
its diameter may measure anything from
90 to 200 kilometers
and the radius of its orbit cannot be
less than 21 000 kilometers
as for its orbital period it is around
12 earth days
the inner makeup of mk2 is thought to be
identical to that of makimaki
however sun rays would have vaporized
the layers of methane snow
that used to cover its surface besides
with almost no gravitation forces
exerted by the satellite to speak of
the gases molecules would have floated
away into space
it is admittedly an extremely slow
process that takes billions of years to
complete
as makimaki's rotation period is
anomalously long
it gives grounds to assume that there is
at least one more
large satellite orbiting it but it still
remains to be discovered
makimaki is currently located almost to
the furthest point of its orbit
which makes it difficult to investigate
it
however sending out an interplanetary
space probe to explore it is hardly
sensible at this point
estimates show that it will take the
spacecraft around 16 years to reach the
planetoid
even taking into account a gravity boost
maneuver near jupiter
just in 150 years
mere seconds in astronomical terms
makimaki will be closer to us than pluto
even though it will take a while sooner
or later
it will certainly reveal its secrets to
us
dear friends it takes a lot of time and
effort to make every video exciting and
informative
every like you give us encourages us and
boosts our motivation
if you'd like to find out more about
this or that object in the solar system
do let us know in the comments please
subscribe if you still haven't done so
and you will never miss our latest
updates let's keep in touch
you